[Musique]
bonjour je suis ravi de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro d' europe et
donnons pas depuis le parlement européen
comme à l'accoutumée dans ce court aux
avis oblige nous traversons une crise
sanitaire 1 depuis des semaines inédite
face à laquelle douze états européens
ont décrété l'état d'urgence
limitation de la circulation encadrement
du rôle du parlement lutte contre les
infections ou encore description drôle
manifesté beaucoup d'états se sont dotés
d'un cadre d'exception autant de
limitation aux libertés individuelles et
collectives prise au nom de la lutte
contre la pandémie
mais était ce nécessaire et surtout
est-ce efficace tout l'état d'urgence
sera utile pour moi georges caroli vous
êtes en baisse de l'ordre de bruit en
france depuis cinq ans bienvenue à vous
j'ai au jour le plaisir d'accueillir
bonjour emmanuel maurel eurodéputés
français vous siéger au sein du groupe
de la gauche unitaire bonjour bon jeu
nous accompagne tout au long de cette
émission deux autres invités deux
citoyennes européennes vont vous écouter
et intervenir pour nous faire part de
leurs remarques et leurs réflexions
depuis madrid
myriam anciaux et saha à londres où elle
je vous dis à tout à l'heure mais dame
ma première question va s'adresser avoue
emmanuel maurel au vu de la situation
sanitaire est nécessaire vraiment
décrété n'est pas d'urgence de prendre
des mesures exceptionnelles à rogner sur
nos libertés nécessaire peut-être mais
en tout cas ce qui est vrai c'est que le
confinement obligatoire en temps de paix
à quelque chose de complètement inédit
parce que vous priver au nom de
l'efficacité au nom de la lutte contre
la pandémie les citoyens d'un droit
absolument fondamental qui est celui
d'aller et venir et voulait priver aussi
de tous les droits à tenon
le droit se réunir leur droit à se
rassembler le droit à manifester le
droit de pratiquer son culte
tout ça c'est des libertés auxquelles
les citoyens ont dû renoncer pour des
motifs sanitaires et ce qui est très
important de mon avis c'est quand même
d'avoir une vigilance particulière par
rapport à toutes les lois du d'état
d'urgence vous y faisiez allusion à
l'instant qui ont été votées dans
certains pays pour que la réponse des
pouvoirs publics soient proportionnées à
la crise est conforme à l'état de droit
5 et reviendra sans doute un peu plus
tard george karl yangi vous avez les
tensions 11 mai est-ce qu'on peut tirer
un premier bilan est ce que cela a été
efficace et cela a permis à votre pays
de jubilé le virus
je tiens à préciser que angry ya eu
environ 500 décès pour le moment pour à
peu près une population de 9 millions
d'habitants
absolument le nombre des décès en
hongrie est très inférieur à ce qu'il
est en proportion dans d'autres pays
il est vraisemblablement due pour partie
aux mesures qui ont été prises il est
peut-être due aussi à d'autres facteurs
de santé ou médicaux que nous révélera
un jour je pense qu'il est beaucoup trop
tôt aujourd'hui de savoir pour quelle
raison ce virus se développe de manière
différente du pays à pays
mais ce qui est certain c'est que la
hongrie a pris très rapidement peut être
même avant beaucoup d'autres pays
un certain nombre de mesures qui forçait
de courtage se sont montrés se sont
montrés efficaces
certains pays un an au sein de l'union
européenne n'ont pas décrété l'état
d'urgence et
et non pas non pas les moindres on parle
notamment de l'allemagne qui a pourtant
eu connu peu de décès par rapport en
tout cas à sa population parce qu'on est
au tour de de 8000 morts donc on peut
faire sans état d'urgence mais ce haka
all it vous avez le l'état d'urgence
perse personnellement je suis confiné
comme tout le monde à paris depuis
depuis depuis plus deux bouts loi je
n'ai jamais considéré que ce confinement
était une atteinte intolérable à la
liberté démocratique d'aller et venir
vous savez la vie n'est pas un long
fleuve tranquille le nom de nos désirs
satisfait il y a des contrariétés tout
le temps même en temps de paix
et lorsque l'événement aussi imprévue
est aussi grave que le coran à demi-nus
tous tombés dessus
je trouve tout à fait normal tu as fait
normal que des mesures soient prises
j'espère justement nous allons voir un
petit peu plus un instant visés par les
mesures adoptées dans le cadre de l'état
d'urgence fabien de reggae redresse pour
un comparatif ensemble
[Musique]
comme la france la hongrie vit
actuellement sous un régime d'exception
en france l'état d'urgence sanitaire
voté le 23 mars a été prolongée jusqu'au
10 juillet la hongrie a quant à elle
décrété l'état d'urgence sanitaire le 11
mars avant qu'il ne soit prolongée
deux semaines plus tard par le parlement
hongrois et ce pour une durée illimitée
une restriction du rôle du parlement
sans date limite qui a fait l'objet de
vives critiques au niveau européen la
commission européenne s'inquiète
notamment des dérogations au droit du
travail permise par l'état d'urgence en
hongrie ainsi que de possibles atteintes
à la protection des données personnelles
autre source d'inquiétude le crime de
diffusion de fausses nouvelles sur le
virus ou sur l'action du gouvernement
passible de cinq ans de prison pour les
organisations de défense de la presse
la mesure ouvre la porte à la censure
récemment deux opposants ont été
interpellés par la police après avoir
critiqué le gouvernement sur facebook
enfin des coupes budgétaires visant
notamment les partis politiques et les
communes
officiellement pour faire des économies
ont suscité l'indignation de
l'opposition hongroise en france non
plus le gouvernement ne s'est pas privé
le légiférer par ordonnances l'exécutif
en a émis plus de 60 depuis le début de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire
elles concernent par exemple la
modification de la procédure pénale
le droit du travail ou le report des
élections municipales consulter à quatre
reprises depuis le début de la crise le
parlement a toutefois joué son rôle sur
le traçage des malades ou le recours à
la mise en quarantaine
les parlementaires ont amendé la loi
pour protéger les libertés
mardi 26 mai le gouvernement hongrois a
déposé une motion au parlement pour
mettre fin aux pouvoirs spéciaux
accordés à viktor orban
la mesure doit encore être voté le fit
days parti du premier ministre dispose
d'une majorité des deux tiers à
l'assemblée ont droit
[Applaudissements]
la levée de l'état d'urgence devrait
intervenir en hongrie 1 le 20 juin
george karl i comment interpréter cette
volte face est ce que cela a que la fin
de la pandémie
ou bien la route via en quelque sorte
céder aux pressions internationales et
européennes
je crois que l'interprétation est très
simple votre le sujet a dit que la
hongrie avait collé parlement hongrois
avaient prolongé l'état d'urgence pour
une durée indéterminée
ce qui se passe en ce moment montrent
que c'est totalement faux la date de
validité de l'état d'urgence était la
même que celle de la durée du danger qui
l'a motivé alors à partir du moment où
le gouvernement hongrois jusque dans son
pays ce danger est passé
eh bien nous mettons fin à l'état
d'urgence emmanuel maurel nombreux sont
ceux à un contenu en france cuse et
victor banal utiliser la crise sanitaire
pour s'octroyer les pleins pouvoirs mais
finalement la hongrie va sans doute en
sortir de l'état d'urgence avant la
france et avant d'autres
l'union européenne elle est il vraiment
s'inquiéter balleux vous savez il ya une
résolution du parlement européen en
avril 2009 1 qui faisait état de ses
préoccupations dont la plupart des pays
européens mais notamment en hongrie et
en pologne parce qu'ils estimaient que
les mesures qui ont été prises par les
parlements n'étaient pas proportionnées
aux exigences de la situation et
n'étaient pas nécessairement conforme à
l'état de droit mais en ce qui concerne
par exemple la hongrie ça n'a rien
d'exceptionnel ça fait des années
maintenant que les autorités européennes
mais aussi le conseil de l'europe mais
aussi un certain nombre de hedge et
dénonce des dérives avérée de monsieur
urban et de son parti alors ongles et
c'est particulièrement le cas avec la
loi sur les faits que nous entre
guillemets qui pouvait justifier cinq
ans d'emprisonnement
mais dans deux pays à commencer par le
mien je le reconnais il ya des
tentations de la part du pouvoir
exécutif de limère de limiter la liberté
d'expression au nom de la lutte contre
cet ennemi invisible que le virus est
bien vraiment il faut sortir de cette
rhétorique faut être très vigilant très
vigilant et je moi je vous posiez la
question
mon avis très légitimement est-ce qu'il
faut nécessairement passer par une
législation d'exception et par la mise
en place d'un état d'urgence moi je ne
suis pas sûr regardé en france par
exemple on est en état d'urgence depuis
2004 on l'entend georges qu'un religieux
dès qu on revienne sur une des mesures
évoquées par emmanuel maurel les
arrestations notamment pour fausses
nouvelles ou fake nous dans le cadre de
l'état d'urgence et qui ont été vivement
dénoncée est perçue comme un moyen de
museler la presse cette mesure en
particulier ce qui était vraiment
justifié vous savez tous pays à un code
pénal dans une période comme celle là il
est tout à fait légitime de veiller à la
diffusion de fausses nouvelles surtout
de fausses nouvelles alarmistes
là je vous signale au passage que la
définition des fausses nouvelles adoptée
par le gouvernement hongrois est
exactement la même que celle de l'union
européenne et je signale aussi avec à
partir d'aujourd'hui d'hier à partir du
moment où décision de lever l'état
d'urgence tout cela donc aussi en ce qui
concerne en revanche et 87 procédure
lancée et elle garde à vue c'est pas le
cas dans tous les pays européens mais
les gardes à vue dont vous parlez ont
été levées certes deux personnes ont été
arrêtées par la police ont droit elles
ont été relâchés après quelques heures
ce sont des événements qui se produisent
dans tous les pays est ce que vous
pouvez me dire qu'en france la police
endroits la police française n'a pas
fait preuve d'un certain excès de zèle
aussi dans certains cas vis-à-vis de
certains gilet jaune c'est quand même la
vice-présidente de la commission
européenne met à jour va qui a réaffirmé
sa préoccupation il ya quelques jours
concernant l'état des ombres et de la
sittelle souhaite que la hongrie
reviennent et ses mots kacou
incontestable emmanuel maurel
elle est contestable la démocratie
hongroise on l'a on vit ça date pas de
l'état d'urgence et de la duc o vie de
19 depuis maintenant plusieurs années
vous avez la commission le conseil de
l'europe le parlement européen un
certain nombre d ong d'institutions
européennes spécialisé dans les droits
de l'homme qui alerte sur des projets de
loi qui ont été voulus par la majorité
sur pas mais monsieur morel vous évoquez
des faits qui datent d'il ya dix ans il
faut savoir terminer voudrais savoir ou
est ce genre de débat enfin cher
monsieur
c'est bon c'est difficile de débattre à
distance mais enfin je voudrais pas vous
rappeler que au sein même de la droite
européenne ce ver le ppe dans lequel
siège le fid est la partie de monsieur
or ban vous avez été mis au ban de ce
parti précisément parce qu'il y avait un
certain nombre d'infractions à l'état de
droit dans votre pays je me permets de
vous couper je voudrais quand même qu'on
regarde il y à une étude en un centre de
recherche allemand qui a comparé les
différents états d'urgence parce que je
revenais d'un petit poème à la
thématique l'état d'urgence au sol
l'union européenne ainsi que voilà et
qui compare les mesures restrictives de
liberté qui capte et moi ainsi été
classés comme portant des attentes c'est
la liberté
c'est le cas de la france c'est le cas
de la hongrie mais c'est également le
cas de l'italie et de l'espagne
emmanuel maurel voilà ma question y at
il aussi un problème démocratique dans
notre pays c'est c'est je suis difficile
de vous répondre en un mot à cette
question particulière mais ce que je
crois en tout cas c'est qu'il ya tout il
ya une dérive lente depuis plusieurs
années
kieren progressivement sur les libertés
publiques y compris en france et vous
avez des gens je vous renvoie à l
ouvrage de l'avocat ce sur aux cayes qui
a écrit un un petit texte chez gallimard
sur la dégradation des libertés
publiques en france dans tous les
domaines ce soit liberté d'expression
françois sureau voilà exactement liberté
d'expression droit de manifester usage
disproportionné de la force des forces
de répression envers des manifestants en
france
tout ça c'est une réalité est donc
aujourd'hui ce qu'il convient de faire
un sursaut au niveau français comme au
niveau européen pour que nous restions
une terre attaché aux droits de l'homme
nous libertés fondamentales vous parlez
de sept critères elle n'a pas acte en
tire des divergences
ancien l'europe démocratique peut-elle
de continuer à avancer en malgré le
fossé qui se creuse
c'est une analyse signée annie capelle
de la carrière d'alex turner
dans cette crise nos libertés à tous ont
été bridée chaque état membre a mis en
place des mesures fortes pour endiguer
l'épidémie forcément il ya eu des
différences dans la réponse apportée par
les uns et les autres
alors on pourrait dire que cela
répondait à des besoins spécifiques et
ponctuels et pourtant dans une large
mesure ces différences étaient là bien
avant le printemps
et c'est crise n'a fait que les
accentuer ça fait des années que viktor
orban même son travail de sape pour
tenter d'imposer son modèle de la
démocratie libérale
il n'a pas attendu le coran navires us
ça fait longtemps que la démocratie est
en crise dans cette partie de l'europe
et ceux coronavirus et bien il agit
comme un amplificateur de cette crise il
amplifie la bataille idéologique entre
deux modèles démocratiques
c'est une solide épreuve pour l'europe
sans doute la plus grave de son
existence lors la question c'est comment
l'union va-t-elle résister il est sans
doute trop tôt pour le savoir
mais certains signes ne trompent pas il
suffit de regarder comment la commission
européenne a réagi face à la décision de
viktor orban de s'accorder les pleins
pouvoirs de façon illimitée elle a réagi
timidement beaucoup trop timidement à
l'instar d'ailleurs de ce qu'elle a fait
ses dernières années qu'en fin mars
viktor orban a obtenu le feu vert de son
parlement
la commission européenne a fait part de
son inquiétude profonde
elle a rappelé que les mesures prises
par les gouvernements les gouvernements
devaient rester proportionnés et de
nature temporaire mais dans un premier
temps elle l'a fait sans même nommé la
hongrie ensuite malgré la demande
pressante du parlement européen elle n'a
pas jugé opportun de prendre des
sanctions vis-à-vis de budapest
donc non seulement cette crise a
accentué les divergences mais elle a
confirmé l'impuissance de la commission
à ramener la hongrie sur le chemin de la
démocratie
george karl yannick capelle parle dans
sa chronique de bataille idéologique
entre deux modèles démocratiques
quelle valeur la hongrie
souhaite défendre en europe écoutez je
suis très étonné sinon scandalisé parce
que cette personne a déclaré dire que la
hongrie n'est pas un pays démocratique
est un scandale majeur disent que
l'union européenne n'a pas réagi
suffisamment vivement est une opinion
politique qui ne fait que démontrer la
frustration
monsieur qui voudrait que la hongrie
soit clouée au pilori de l'europe du
matin jusqu'au soir ce qui est
absolument inadmissible
là on dit je vous le rappelle en prenant
les mesures de son état d'urgence ne
nous a pas prises pour maintenir une
dignité on est en fait celui de
reprendre ce qui aujourd'hui n'existe
plus et ce qui n'a jamais existé
connaît on est en plein dans le procès
d'intention
là on dit fx mais la haine d'autres quel
malheur là on espère défendre en europe
qui dépend de ce qu'on entend par le vos
valeurs
moi je récuse absolument je ne comprends
pas d'ailleurs pour quelle raison on
nous reproche de ne pas respecter les
valeurs de l'europe étant donné que la
hongrie comme des 26 autres pays membres
font partie des valeurs européennes et
lounge estimant que les valeurs ce que
nous défendons peu sont parfaitement
propres sont de même nature et de même
niveau que celle défendue par tous les
pays maintenant chacun à sa façon de
voir un certain nombre de choses nous
avons sur les grandes questions de
société une vision différente de celle
de l'europe occidentale
je ne vois pas pour quelle raison il
faudrait que nous soyons du matin
jusqu'au soir
cloué au pilori pour avoir une vision
différente de la famille et du mariage
de la vie de la relation ans prénommé
une femme tout ça ce sont des questions
tu peux faire débat qui font d'ailleurs
débat mais qui n'ont aucune raison
d'être stigmatisés et ostracisés
emmanuel maurel est ce qu'il ya des
valeurs et fondements desquels on peut
transiger
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on ne peut pas
transiger avec eux les textes
fondamentaux qui je parle je pense
notamment à la charte des droits
fondamentaux qui régissent le permet
c'est l'article 2 emmanuel maurel
l'union est fondée sur les valeurs de
respect de la dignité humaine de liberté
de démocratie d'égalité de l'état de
droit ainsi que de respect des droits de
l'homme y compris les droits des
personnes appartenant à des minorités
est ce qu'on peut transiger avec
certaines de ses valeurs et ses
fondamentaux
bah non je ne crois pas sinon l'union
européenne n'est plus le projet
politique d'unification d'un continent
autour de principes forts ça n'est juste
qu'un grand marché dans ce cas là il ya
un certain nombre d'européens qui
trouvant sera moins intéressant mais je
reviens sur la question vous avez posé à
l'instant monsieur l'ambassadeur
il ya un projet politique de la hongrie
de monsieur or ban
d'ailleurs c'est confirmé regardé hier
monsieur urban a salué un homme
politique européen
un seul c'est monsieur salvini et il ya
une convergence de vues entre les deux
c'est le nationalisme proche de
l'extrême droite qui prône une certaine
vision en effet de la vie en société et
de la construction européenne c'est pas
la mienne je lacombe a fermement mais
quand même
j'ajoute un point qui ne devrait pas
faire débat vous dites on a le droit
d'avoir chacun notre conception de la
famille de du rôle des hommes et des
femmes dans la société
certes mais quand même dans la charte
des droits fondamentaux à laquelle vous
êtes obligés de souscrire quand vous
adhérer à l'union européenne
il ya des choses très précis sur le
droit des minorités sexuelles le droit à
l'éducation sexuelle pour les pour les
femmes l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes le droit d'être d'avoir la
sexualité de son choix va ça pour le
coup c'est des choses qui ne devrait pas
être remise en cause par les
gouvernements
or c'est le cas dans certains
gouvernements notamment d'europe de
l'est
et ça ça pose un problème parce que on
sort du cadre qui est définie par la
charte des droits fondamentaux
que voulez-vous à monsieur morel vous
savez le l'article 2 du traité loi
européenne dénonce un certain nombre de
principes
notamment celui de l'étude de l'état de
droit que de l'assemblee bien évidemment
respecte quand vous dites monsieur morel
qu'on ne peut pas transiger sur ces
principes je suis bien évidemment
d'accord et encore faut-il savoir les
sens qu'on donne aux mots transiger ce
sont des grands principes
ce ne sont pas des règles normatives qui
font l'objet d'un compte rendu de la
part des états c'est considérer ces
fameuses valeurs qui sont énoncés dans
l'article 80 dans l'article 2 peuvent
elles-mêmes être interprété dans un
certain cadre donnant en sortir de sa
cave
mais elles ne sont pas figées elles ne
sont pas d'interprétation uniforme par
tout le monde c'est tout ce que nous
souhaitons elles revêtent un caractère
obligatoire il faut quand même le dire
le dire l'article 2 qui expose
obligatoires évidemment qu'elle revête
un caractère obligatoire mais encore une
fois puisque c'est que l'état de droit
qui est capable de me dire ce qu'est
l'état de droit personne l'état de droit
est une notion extrêmement basique en
mai à banon messi mais parce que l'état
de droit confort voyez ça c'est bien le
problème mais non l'état de droit est un
principe dans le ciel vous mettez un
certain nombre de règles normatives et
pourtant ces règles là que l'on examine
une par une pour savoir si dans tel ou
tel éclat la démocratie l'égalité des
sexes et puisque vous voulez est
correctement respecté en ce qui concerne
la hongrie je ne vois pas pourquoi je ne
vois pas où l'état de droit avec un
grand a et 1,2 md serait mené là il ya
une vraie différence d'interprétation
parce que monsieur l'ambassadeur vient
de dire oui mais moi je ne sais pas
définir l'état de droit si justement
l'état doit il ya des définitions
juridiques très précises j'ai enseigné
le droit constitutionnel pendant dix ans
je peux vous dire que le premier cours
sur l'état de droit
on avait des définitions s'est pas
seulement des principes contrairement à
ce que vous dites
les principes après l'ondé traduction
concrète dans les textes de loi dans les
garanties qui sont proposés
aussi les moyens et tout ça mais je suis
désolé mais ça fait bouger beaucoup de
notes et à ce que dit l'autre s'il n'y
avait pas des divergences
d'interprétation où serions nous nous
avons quand même encore le droit de
débattre sur ce qu'est l'état de droit
il avait enseigné le droit
constitutionnel pendant dix ans
moi je les ai étudié en mobilisant
s'entraîner mais je sais je sais très
bien je sais très bien que nenê les
lignes au tec son plein une liste qui
essaye de définir ce qu'est l'état de
droit moi je veux bien tout ce qu'on
voit bien on voit bien là que en tout
cas il ya un débat et qu'il ya des
divergences cette cotation messieurs
depuis le début de ce débat deux
citoyennes vous écoutent attentivement
je vais vous les présenter et myriam en
chauffe d'être manager en ressources
humaines vous êtes française mais vous
habitez à madrid 1-2 puis 2018 et puis
il ya également saâne film vous êtes
belle je vous avais 36 ans vous êtes
consultant il vous habitez bruxelles
myriam si vous aviez une chose voilà que
vous retenez de ce débat de cet échange
autour
voilà d'état droit des libertés quel
serait-il moi ce que je retiens quand
même de tous ces débats un finalement
dans une situation de crise donc il
s'agit pas d'un qui toucha à l'assumer
finalement des populations finalement
tout le focus va sur des intérêts
politiques ou bien sur des orientations
politiques et sur une limitation des
droits qui final on voit pas venir la
relation finalement avec la protection
de la survie entre guillemets toute la
focalisation bave sur les attitudes
individuelles les droits individuels nos
libertés individuelles
il ya quand même un manque énorme
finalement d'information et de et
détruisent de dynamique sur comment
est-ce qu'on peut solutionner ça en
actions de forme coordonnées de forme
coopérative parce que finalement on
entend parler d'opposition
on entend parler de divergences
d'opinion on entend parler de l'unité à
l'extrême les droits individuels puisque
je pense que dans l'europe il ya eu des
thèmes mesures qui ont été prises
l'espagne comme vous l'avait dit il ya
des mesures qui ont été très très très
intrusive dans la vie privée mais
quelque part avec une espèce de message
relayé que chaque individu n'a pas bhl à
de prendre la mesure de la gravité de la
situation et donc il vaut mieux
finalement le restreindre au maximum et
le petit site est justement doit passer
à la dernière partie de l'émission où
toutes les deux un vous allez nous
raconter comment vous avez concrètement
vécu ces restrictions liberté en espagne
et en belgique
mais avant je vais remercier emmanuel
maurel 1 et georges caroni d'avoir
participé à ce débat
merci à tous les deux leur mission
direction madrid où vous habitez myriam
un confinement très stricte depuis des
semaines encore aujourd'hui vous n'êtes
autorisé à sortir que très peu de chez
vous c'est ça il a été décidé de passer
en face une de 3 0 une deux trois quatre
qui est finalement redonne un certain
nombre de libertés fondamentales la
situation en espagne c'est que pour le
moment bien certaines régions qui sont
par exemple en face d'eux au point sur
le point de passer en phase iii c'est à
dire en reprenant là qu'on fasse vertain
mais voyez comment avoir des mouvements
contestation 1 contre ces mesures
restrictives
oui mais en réalité elles ont été très
très forte et surtout il n'y a pas eu
forcément beaucoup de compréhension sur
pourquoi on pouvait passer ou pas de
phrase
il ya beaucoup de débat politique autour
de ça et d'une manière générale il ya
même une grosse contestation qui se lève
dans dans le pays et des oppositions
finalement entre entre idéologies
politiques encore une fois entre ceux
qui considèrent que les mesures ont été
excessives au présent duré trop
longtemps on a fermé les parcs comme
vous voyez les enfants peuvent pas
sortir de personne ne peut aller courir
adapté à l'écran vous personnellement ce
que vous les avez de compris ces
restrictions aux libertés des premiers
les premiers temps évidemment quand on
est face à une crise on comprend que le
temps de s'organiser il faut quand même
y mettre du sien en tout le monde le
comprend et c'est logique il faut un
petit temps d'adaptation maintenant le
prolongement de cette façon avec
vraiment une intrusion niveau personnel
par exemple les membres d'une même
famille pouvait pas voyager dans une
voiture on veut pas changer de région on
peut pas sortir à plus de x 100 mètres
de chez soi on pouvait pas l'écrire un
ministre au début comme je vous disais
c'est quand même un niveau de détails
dans ce qui est interdit de faire
quelques scènes assez élevée face un
finalement un délai très très long pour
avoir un début de compréhension de ce
qui peut être fait pour retourner
vie normale l'entente mais il ya
beaucoup d' entrave je voudrais
également entendre taha al faim depuis
bruxelles il est moins de restriction en
belgique clairement mais vous dites vous
avez dit quand apparaît mission que
c'est très cool qui ont elles expliqué
nous effectivement et on a gardé
toujours la possibilité de se balader
seul ou avec un ami
donc c'est quelque chose qui étaient
invérifiables étant donné qu'il n'y a
pas de système d'attestation et donc il
y avait vraiment une collaboration qui a
été demandé aux citoyens et on était je
trouve plus dans une démarche d'adhésion
de co-création avec ce qui se passait
plutôt que d'obéissance unilatérale à
des règles venu dans j'ai pu constater
que c'était culturel j'avais peur qu'on
tombe dans l'aspect très français et
enfin pardon pour répondre à votre
question effectivement parce que je
m'inquiétais du coup de l'état un peu
psychologique de mes amis a basé en
france et en particulier à paris et
finalement il acceptait il comprenait en
fait il fallait en passer par là en
france plus de faire respecter les
consignes et en belgique n'a pas du tout
été le cas
en fait les on a pu constater une
adhésion effective et à ce quasi
immédiate de l'entièreté de la grande
majorité de la population dès le départ
en fait il n'a pas du tout fallu qu'on
passe par des menaces de d'amande qui
pleuvent et c'est vrai que moi
personnellement j'ai j'appréhendais un
peu que quatre stations soient mis en
place en belgique est aussi varié qui
m'avait choqué c'était que j'ai entendu
quand en france après quatre fois où
vous étiez prise dans une certain laps
de temps centre attestation on parlait
même de peines de prison non mais il y
avait surtout les amendes en tout cas où
on voit bien là entre l'espagne la
france et la belgique
des divergences d'approchés on va
s'arrêter là merci à toutes les pour vos
témoignages dès la fin de cette émission
vous pouvez la voir et la revoir sur
notre site publicsenat.fr mais également
sur l'antenne de la rtbf
à très bientôt pour de nouvelles
européennes
[Musique]